where does the creation of a great story
begin I think it varies from story to
story from writer to writer you know
I've interviewed so many of them some of
them start with a theme I don't do that
you know theme of central theme of
themes or a central theme of a story
will emerge over time but some people
start off with a thematic point of view
a lot of people start that I have
interviewed and this is more where I'm
at start off with a character or
characters and I think that works
because if the character is interesting
and you can mine that then that's where
people can find those points of
connection some start off with a story
concept I I do this thing on my blog
I've done it now ten straight years yet
ten years called a story idea each day
for a month so in April every April 30
days I collect stories along the way in
my computer and then I just run one that
each day and I say okay so here's the
basis of this news article what would we
do with is if there were a movie and get
people to think about this I'd say what
if we did this is a drama wait a minute
what do we did this is a thriller what
if you despond it this way like I just
heard one on the way over this is
amazing so a guy is a Dallas Love Field
today a passenger you know waiting to
take off when there's this hubbub there
and as it turns out they're bringing
back to the body the remains of a guy
who fought for the United States in
Vietnam and they've recently discovered
his remains his son was five when he
last saw his father at that base leaving
to go to Vietnam the pilot of the plane
flying his father's remains to Dallas is
his son is that amazing so they they had
all of the people like all those people
who do the luggage and they created
these line
and they had a water they were doing a
water troubie they're shooting with a
fire hoses and stuff they had military
guys there and the guy who said it was
that everybody was pressed up against
the windows because this word had spread
that this was happening and he said it
was the irias thing
nobody's phone nobody talking nope the
luggage everybody just standing still
watching this reverent moment happened
so I'd say things like the news articles
you know I don't know if that's a great
story or not but it's it's a it's a
wonderful moment but maybe that's an
opportunity to be you know a story so I
think it can happen from anywhere you
know be open to it the magic words what
if right mark Norman's son calls him up
and says what if Shakespeare had
writer's block and that was the
inspiration for Shakespeare in Love and
hook written by James V Hart came about
like breakfast conversation where his
son said what if Peter Pan grew up so I
think concepts are big I think they're
really important now maybe as important
as they were the can high concept thing
that we talked about in the 80s and 90s
so much because of this whole idea that
unless you've got some sort of
pre-existing IP you know Hollywood
scared to green-light that so it takes a
really really strong concept a strong
story concept
so I'd say theme characters story
concept I mean those are all you know I
love the Coen brothers the way that
Miller's Crossing started was this image
of a hat being tossed across a creek in
the woods
that was literally where that started so
whatever it is you know find if you're
passionate about it and if you're
passionate about it they've done right
the hell out of it you know I'm sorry
why have the screenplays changed in
terms of reading one let's say from 20
years ago from 1/2 years ago in terms of
are they are things written in a briefer
manner yes now this is where one area I
feel pretty confident that I understand
pretty well I used to teach a class
called the history of American screen
writing which was created by my
colleague down at the University of
North Carolina Dana Cohen and I taught
that class I think four times and it was
really a brilliant class because it
would go decade by decade starting with
like in the 1890s every week was like a
different decade 1900s and 1910s 1920s
and so you're studying the evolution of
screen writing and filmmaking
particularly in the United States and
the role of the screenwriter in the
process particularly in Hollywood one of
the things that we did in that class was
we looked at screenplay structure and
format and style as it evolved over time
in fact the term screenplay didn't
really come into existence until the 30s
and 40s before then it was known was
basically just a shot list and then it
became known as a continuity during the
silent film era but then what's talkies
came along then they started bringing in
Hollywood started to bring all these
playwrights did the dialogue right and
so then it became a screen play two
words so if you look at movies from the
30s and even into the 40s you'll
oftentimes see that credit being screen
play as a screen version of a play so
then eventually screenplays kind of
became a little bit more of their own
thing and we joined them together a
screenplay so I've studied this quite
you know comprehensively and I know for
a fact that it's always evolving so
that's always cracked me up when people
say well you can't do this or you have
to do that it's always evolving it's
constantly evolving so for example if
you look at if you look at scripts from
there were no things as selling scripts
or spec scripts back in the 40s and 50s
and 60s it was all for hire well 40s and
50s thirties forties and fifties and so
is all all these things were filled with
shots you know close-up zoom and all
that stuff what happened what's the spec
script market evolved was director said
we don't want it we don't want you to
tell us how to direct the movie
we're director's we're gonna do that so
then we pulled out that journal a
speaking we pulled out that camera
jargon and directing lingo
and so that led to the whole we see we
move we hear and then that started to
get a bit tiresome and so then what we
started to do was just just describe
what's happening and so then when I
first broken was like okay so every
paragraph you should try to have no more
than five lines as opposed to like these
big blocks of 15 20 30 lines because
it's much easier to read script readers
are in effect the threshold Guardians of
Hollywood and we try to make it as easy
for them to read as possible nowadays I
think that you know the general feeling
and this is not a rule but the general
feeling is that the paragraph should be
no longer than three lines but a better
way to think about it does not like that
sort of regimented thing I think the
better way to think about it is each
line of scene description each paragraph
of scene description that's a way of
indicating a camera shot
you're not saying it's a camera shot but
if you think about the scene as you're
writing it and you're thinking okay
that's a close-up I see that is a
close-up and I see this as a as a wide
shot and I see this is a medium shot now
you're not saying that in the script but
you're breaking up each paragraph to
suggest that that's a camera shot that's
a great way to not only direct the
action on the page but also ensure that
your paragraphs aren't that long you're
breaking them up into one two or three
lines so scripts today this is why it's
important yeah it's great to read the
older scripts but it's really important
to read the scripts that come out
nowadays because the styles are
constantly changing we're seeing
something happening right now and I
don't know if it's going to continue to
go this way but including images and
scripts like if you read the script that
Brian woods and Scott Beck did for a
quiet place it has an image of their
Monopoly board it's got an image
comparing like the Statue of Liberty and
I think the Eiffel Tower and then this
big tower that's out in the field
they're just so you get a sense of it
they change font sizes they use one page
is like a word on it or even a letter
you know so it's much more
usually graphic and I guess it makes
sense because movies are primarily a
visual medium some people may resist
that as being kind of a cheat but we're
starting to see some of that now and I
don't think that's necessarily wrong it
could be that we eventually that's what
screenplays become they do include
images and you could certainly make an
argument that why not
because again it's a it's a visual
medium so it's constantly in a state of
change which is why if anybody tells you
you can't do this or you have to do that
then then you know you're not talking to
the right people
you need to read scripts by professional
screenwriters and see what they do and
realize that we have a lot of latitude
to tell the story the best way it needs
to be told and maybe that's why emojis
and different things have seeped into I
don't know if you've received papers
then it happens like an emoji in there
or here or there but it's become part of
communication images you see them in
scripts because of texting now you know
we would we didn't have texting you know
until 15 years ago or whatnot right so
when you don't you know some people will
mind university students will try to do
that as dialog is it's not really
dialogue it's its own thing and so that
the typical thing now is to to do left
margin' just like you're doing action
right and you do you know the name of
the character : and then their little
texting thing and it can have an emoji
in it and then you do a shift enter you
don't do two lines or the line space you
do shift enter so it's right under there
the next text shift enter the next text
and that's how most people that I know
handle texting but yeah emojis would be
there we wouldn't you know we wouldn't
who knows in 10 years we'll be doing
something different and that's gonna be
reflected and screenplays you know kind
of matrix thing yeah
you